[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez les européennes à prolonger cette
discussion faute d'accord sur un plan de
relance les 27 ont repris aujourd'hui
les négociations sur fond de profondes
divergences la concerne un plan de
relance il y ait la crise une
coronavirus à la crainte d'un échec
plane sur ce troisième jour de sommet à
bruxelles
en israël la reprise aujourd'hui du
procès pour corruption de benyamin
nétanyahou la grogne contre le
gouvernement s'intensifie de jour en
jour hier à des milliers de personnes
ont manifesté à jérusalem et tel aviv
pour dénoncer les malversations au plus
haut niveau et aussi la gestion de la
pandémie siens et puis en y danser les
élections législatives
aujourd'hui plus de 7000 bureaux de vote
ont ouvert ce matin scrutin sous haute
tension dans un pays marqué par un
conflit meurtrier et qui dure depuis
neuf ans il ya une explosion a fait un
mort dans la banlieue sud de damas
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france à bruxelles en
redoutant un échec sans le plan de
relance post coronavirus les discussions
ont repris aujourd'hui troisième jour de
sommet européen
et hier pas de compromis trouvé entre
les vingt-sept les pays-bas et ses
alliés peinent à accepter un plan qui
bénéficierait au pays
elle est plus touché par la pandémie la
dernière journée de négociations dont
crucial faut-il y croire emmanuel macron
le veut la chancelière allemande et son
homologue autrichien sont plus partagés
tomita skilling nous sommes très
préoccupés par la bonne utilisation des
fonds alloués
il faut un contrôle une bonne
gouvernance mais il est vrai que les
négociations sont difficiles mais il ya
aussi des progrès aujourd'hui nous
entrons dans la troisième journée de
négociation et c'est certainement la
plus décisive les différentes questions
la taille du fonds le type de contrôle
ríos il est question de l'état de droit
ont maintenant été bien traités je ne
peux toujours pas dire si une solution
sera trouvée il y a beaucoup de bonne
volonté mais il ya aussi beaucoup de
prises de positions je les soutiendrai
donc mais il se peut aussi qu'aucun
résultat ne soit adoptée une mais
aujourd'hui c'est la question du montant
de ce fonds de relance où elle l'a aussi
nous avons des dissensions des
sensibilités différentes qui sont
apparus voilà les principaux sujets qui
sont devant nous et sur lesquels il nous
faut trouver les bons compromis dans les
prochaines heures je pense que c'est
encore possible mais ces compromis je le
dis très clairement ne se feront pas au
prix de l'ambition européenne détention
également dans ce sommet viktor orban le
premier ministre hongrois accusent les
pays bas 2 vouloir à les punir
financièrement regarder sa réaction je
ne sais pas quelle est la raison
personnelle pour laquelle le premier
ministre néerlandais me déteste c'est
moi ou la hongrie mais il attaque si
durement est dit très clairement que
parce que la hongrie selon lui il ne
respecte pas l'état de droit elle doit
être puni financièrement c'est sa
position qui n'est pas acceptable parce
qu'il n'y a pas de décision
sur la situation de l'état de droit on
rit à la solidarité européenne donc un
mise à l'épreuve lors de ce sommet à
bruxelles à des négociations difficiles
qui font ressurgir les désaccords entre
les 27 allez précision c'est avec eric
cottier coffey bassam chez lui il est
temps d'agir
il est temps de décider cette
déclaration du 10 juillet du président
du conseil européen charles michel
résonnait encore en pleine après
tractations ce week end à bruxelles
à l'origine un plan de relance de 750
milliards d'euros à l'initiative du
couple franco-allemand et j'ai retrouvé
en gala merkel pour avancer sur le plan
de relance européen que nous portons
ensemble
ce plan va permettre de surmonter la
crise économique et sociale que nous
traversons
l'europe en a besoin notre objectif est
simple mobiliser au moins 500 milliards
d'euros de subventions tourner vers les
régions les plus touchées
pour réussir nous devons obtenir un
accord à vingt-sept lors du prochain
conseil européen de mi juillet nous
allons poursuivre les négociations et
tout faire pour convaincre nos
partenaires problème quatre états
s'oppose fermement à cette opération
qu'ils jugent déséquilibrée pays bas
autriche danemark et suède alias les
frigos ou encore les radins de l'union
européenne comme ils sont surnommés par
leurs détracteurs et bien des raisons de
s'opposer aux modalités de ce week aubry
found s'il ne rejette pas le prêt de 250
milliards d'euros ils remettent en
question la mutualisation de la dette à
hauteur elle de 500 milliards
le club des 4 se dit prête à venir en
aide aux voisins les plus touchés par la
crise du coronavirus tels que l'italie
ou encore l'espagne condition
sinequanone des prêts et non des
subventions comme réclamée par paris et
berlin
alors pourquoi une telle résistance tout
d'abord leur taux d'endettement est
parmi les plus faibles de l'union euros
autre argument ils sont contributeurs
nets au budget de l'union européenne
traduction ils donnent plus qu'ils ne
reçoivent marque route
le premier ministre néerlandais chef de
file des frigos souhaite un vote à
l'unanimité à chaque fois qu'une tranche
d'argent devra être débloqués mais ces
pays sont ils réellement les moins
endettés de l'union européenne sont ils
les seuls contributeurs nets de la zone
pas si sûr que ça car les taux
d'endettement privé danois et
néerlandais sont parmi les plus élevés
au monde due notamment à la dette des
ménages qui dépasse largement celle de
la grèce par exemple concernant leur
statut de contributeurs nets qu'il met
en avant il semblerait que vienne
amsterdam copenhague stockholm ne soient
pas les seuls de l'ue à rome et au même
titre contributeurs nets et sa
contribution à l'union européenne en
2018 était bien plus importante
dernier point mais pas des moindres
trois de ces quatre pays bénéficient de
rabais dans le cadre pluriannuel de
l'union euros le rabais c'est ce
mécanisme de correction du budget
européen qui consiste en un accord entre
l'union européenne et certains de ses
états membres qui les exempte
partiellement de contribuer on l'aura
compris une sphère tendues à bruxelles
ce week-end sur fond de divergences et
de crispation de groupes qui vont devoir
trouver très vite un terrain d'entente
afin de sortir de ces négociations qui
s'enlise et illustre une nouvelle fois
l'impasse d'une union européenne qui
n'en a plus guère que le nom agir et
décider comme l'appelait de ses voeux
charles michel
n'est ce pas au fond un jeu de consensus
et de compromis qui pour certains
experts pourrait marquer le déclin d'une
union européenne déjà bien fragilisé
il y a décidément de petites économies
qui peuvent s'avérer très coûteuse sur
la durée et pour en parler nous sommes
avec pascal de l'image chef économiste
d'harwell management auteur du livre à
capitalisme à et technologies les
liaisons dangereuses aux éditions forme
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec moi en
direct par arte france alors encore une
chance ou pas devoir à un accord ce soir
ou dans la nuit
il y à il ya une chance de voir un
accord effectivement parce que il y a
d'abord de bonnes raisons d'y croire la
première c'est que nous avons déjà
quelque part réussi à faire un peut
infléchir l'allemagne sur cette position
de la mutualisation de la dette en
particulier
et puis ensuite il y à une situation de
crise économique
malheureusement qui cette fois ci oblige
oblige l'europe à ne pas échouer et donc
c'est presque la dernière chance pour
construire une europe fédérale donc
quelque part ces deux raisons qui font
qu'il n'est qu'on ne peut qu'espérer et
ce serait vraiment très regrettable pour
l'europe
si cette fois ci elle ne prenait pas le
virage comme ça a été le cas notamment
la crise de la dette grecque par exemple
le pire scénario ferait quoi finalement
s'il n'y a pas d'accord au terme de
cette troisième journée de négociation à
bruxelles elle aura un autre faux mais
est ce que il faut tout revoir à 0 là si
ce qui se passe c'est qu'on va retomber
dans des accords sur des montants plus
faibles parce que là on a des montants
considérables 750 milliards c'est
l'occasion de d'initier un fédéralisme
européen donc si c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui on va retomber sur des
négociations est d accord qu on connaît
maintenant depuis des années dont
d'ailleurs il va être partie des
européens en a placé
et puis surtout ça va être encore une
fois des pays je dirais comme la france
l'allemagne bref qui sont extrêmement
bien notée par les agences de notation
qui vont pouvoir se développer
emprunter à des taux extrêmement
intéressant et donc finalement c'est le
risque de faire prolonger
certaine façon une europe à deux
vitesses qui existent déjà depuis un
certain temps aujourd'hui c'est un
effort de solidarité commandement
l'allemagne faire un premier pas et il y
à une crise sanitaire avec des
conséquences économiques graves qui font
finalement que l'europe ne peut pas
cette fois ci passer à côté de
l'histoire
c'est peut-être sa dernière chance
peut-être est en tout cas sa dernière
chance d'aller vers quelque chose un peu
plus fédérale et de commencer à
construire une véritable europe sur la
base de projets que l'on connaît
numérique c'est social avec des
ressources communes etc
à défaut de d'aboutir à un accord
finalement ces négociations est ce qu
elles ne sont pas le reflet il faisait
allusion à 2-2 europe qui s'affrontent
qui c'est qui ce qui n'aura dit viser
une europe solidaire et l'europe non
solidaire alors en fait c'est un peu il
ya deux problèmes le premier aussi un
problème lié au fait que les décisions
sont prises à l'unanimité donc si les
pays bas refusent une dette commune et
bien les décisions sont pas prises
la façon dont sont nous les décisions
sont prises au sein de l'union
européenne en termes démocratique
finalement une haine le principe de
l'unanimité complique énormément les
choses on n'est pas dans des principes
de majorité donc ça c'est un premier
point
le deuxième point c'est que aujourd'hui
il est lé fruit beau en fait un bon pays
bas autriche et danemark suède danemark
suède en dehors de la zone euro donc
ceux qui sont les plus réfractaires au
principe d'un plan de relance avec une
dette mutualisée commune avec des
ressources communes pose quand même des
conditions qui sont pas remis du âmes
errantes un qui est celle de pouvoir
contrôler les fonds qu'ils essaient de
pouvoir s'assurer le plein développement
démocratique des états voilà il ya quand
même des choses qui sont pas
complètement incohérente et puis aussi
le fait qu'il souhaite qu'une part de
prêts soit c'est à dire de comment dire
d'investissement qui puisse être
remboursée
la part des prêts soit plus élevé que la
part des subventionnements en tout cas
par rapport à ce qui existe aujourd'hui
donc
voilà c'est juste quelque part ce qu'ils
demandent c'est de responsabiliser un
tout petit peu davantage le pays du sud
si on peut le dire de cette façon là
face à un simple sur un véritable
engagement totalement transparent sur
les fonts finalement qui sont qui seront
alloués par des pays qui quelque part
aussi un peu mieux gérer cette crise que
les autres et donc ils ont aussi un
droit de parole institutionnelle par
rapport à ces questions là certains pays
européens la hongrie et voit d'un très
mauvais oeil s'est fait conditionnalités
imposées à ces pays du sud
alors ils sont effectivement tous types
à part je dirais mais effectivement là
la vraie question c'est c'est que on
peut pas continuer un peu ce qu'on avait
fait à l'époque de la crise grecque et
qu' il faut trouver un juste équilibre
entre le contrôle des fonds par des
réformes qui sont finalement très
souvent des réformes très proche de
politiques d'austérité dont les citoyens
ont tassé finalement et puis en même
temps ne pas aller dans l'autre extrême
qui consiste à ne pas regarder un peu ce
qui ce qui se fait en matière de voilà
c'est quand même 750 milliards alors la
croissance économique de l'union
européenne et 15 mille milliards donc ça
fait après que sa conscience pas non
plus c'est des montants importants
valeur absolue mais il faut aussi quand
même relativiser cela bref pour résumer
je dirais vraiment continuer dans cet
équilibre entre austérité et croissance
est quelque part l'on voit ou raison
aussi comme les frigos de demander des
contreparties en regard de cela merci
beaucoup à vous pascal de lima d'avoir
répondu à nos questions j'appelle quand
vous êtes chef économiste d'harwell
management et auteur de capitalisme a
aidé technologies les liaisons
dangereuses aux éditions forte merci à
vous et bonne soirée
dans l'actualité en israël la reprise
aujourd'hui du procès pour corruption de
benyamin nétanyahou la gronde populaire
s'intensifie en cause les malversations
et aussi la gestion de la crise
sanitaire hier des milliers de
manifestants sont descendus dans la rue
elle et précision c'est avec un mathilde
romagnan menteur manipulateur les
tracteurs de benyamin nétanyahou ne
ménagent pas leurs mots ils étaient des
milliers d'israéliens ont manifesté hier
soir à tel aviv contre leur premier
ministre des défilés ont lieu
régulièrement depuis plus d'un mois mais
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux à la
proche du procès de benyamin nétanyahou
ce dimanche le chef de gouvernement
israélien comparaît pour corruption
fraude et abus de confiance dans trois
affaires une première audience avait
lieu en mai dernier
vendredi les manifestants se sont rendus
devant la résidence du premier ministre
pour demander sa démission
nous sommes jeunes les israéliens de
tout le pays nous sommes fatigués de la
corruption du racisme et de la violence
de netanyahou et nous sommes ici pour
dire arrêtez la corruption arrêter la
violence
arrêté le racisme et nous sommes ici
pour protester et dire netanyahu va en
prison rentre chez toi laisse nous tuer
un dictateur nous ne voulons pas de toi
je suis venue manifester pour la justice
et la justice c'est aussi que le premier
ministre est accusé de crime et sera
traduit en justice et qu'il cessera de
l'éviter la justice et aussi aider les
faibles ce gouvernement est complètement
perdue il est un dictateur qui fait
taire tout le monde et les riches
contrôle la police et le parlement
je pense que tant que nous occupons
d'autres peuples et que nous leur
imposons un régime militaire nous ne
pouvons pas nous attendre à voir un
gouvernement
qu'auront pu avoir un revenu stable et à
vivre dignement comme des êtres humains
je ne comprends pas comment moi en tant
qu'israélien je peux espérer obtenir mes
droits tant que nous occupons d'autres
peuples
la grogne populaire s'est intensifié
après l'annnonce de nouvelles mesures de
restriction pour ralentir l'épidémie de
kovy 19 qui regagne du terrain et à la
crise sanitaire s'ajoute la crise
économique le taux de chômage en israël
a bondi dépassant les 20% selon un
sondage de la chaîne 13 publié cette
semaine 61% des électeurs se disent
mécontents de la gestion de l'épidémie
par benyamin nétanyahou en écoute
l'analyse de jacques benillouche et les
journalistes heures indépendant en
israël
la critique du président de la banque
d'israël qui est un président qui est
nommé par netanyahu lui-même et qui
aujourd'hui critique en perm à lens le
gouvernement en disant que les nouvelles
élues me mais les méthodes de piau été
utilisés et les mesures ont été choisis
ne sont pas bonnes donc aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une période critique
or on ne peut pas fermer tous les
commerces c'est dramatique on ne peut
pas fermer toutes les industries et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on pense que natanyahou
agi par intermittences sans réflexion je
prendrais simplement un exemple il
décide de fermer les restaurants et puis
certains restaurateurs leur billet coûte
nous avons des stocks de marchandises
des stocks de viande de nourriture on
peut pas les jeter
alors nathalie ont valu ok on va
prolonger de deux ou trois jours votre
interdiction
cela veut dire que ce sont des décisions
qui sont prises sans concertation
l'opposition et est absolument absente
dans ce domaine seulement dans les rues
et c'est là c'est nouveau c'est que
l'opposition n'est pas à la knesset
l'opposition et dans la rue et c'est
grave parce que quand on est dans la rue
on peut avoir des des problèmes on peut
avoir des ddd des attaques éventuelles
contre la police et c'est ce qui
m'inquiète un peu c'est qu'on passe de
la knesset à la rue on en vient aux
législatives a enterré un scrutin sous
tensions dans un pays
ravagé par la guerre le président syrien
bachar al assad s'est lui rendu aux
urnes ce matin plus de 7400 bureaux de
vote
en tout hier deux explosions ont fait un
mort à damas selon l'agencé de presse
officielle sana
pourtant les enjeux de ces élections
sont énormes économiques et sociaux plus
de 80% de la population vit sous le
seuil de la pauvreté selon les nations
unies les détails avec david khalifa
l'effervescence d'une élection à chaque
coin de rue ou presque
des affiches de candidats aux
législatives l'espoir d'une
normalisation pour ce pays en pleine
reconstruction
frappé de plein fouet par des sanctions
occidentales et une crise économique
d'ampleur depuis 2011 et le début d'un
conflit qui a coûté la vie à des
milliers de personnes c'est la troisième
fois que les syriens sont appelés aux
urnes pour des législatives qui coïncide
cette année avec les vingt ans au
pouvoir du président bachar al assad
la configuration 2100 candidats en lice
pour 250 sièges de députés ont repoussé
à deux reprises en raison du kobe 19
ces élections revêtent des enjeux claire
reconstruire le pays et contrôler
l'inflation
les revendications des gens sont des
demandes simples pour vivre leur
préoccupation est de savoir comment
obtenir de la nourriture et autres
nécessités du quotidien
grand favori du scrutin le parti bass
lié à bachar al assad est au pouvoir
depuis un demi siècle
comme un symbole certains syriens se
rendront dans d'anciens bastions des
insurgés pour voter en tout sept mille
trois cent treize bureaux de vote seront
mises à disposition des électeurs sur le
plan économique la syrie confronté à la
pire crise de son histoire aggravée par
une forte dépréciation de sa monnaie et
des mesures punitives imposées par les
états unis des sanctions que damas
déplore
si les états unis rêve que la syrie et
son peuple se soumettent à leur
condition alors je dis qu'ils peuvent
continuer à rêver car cela n'arrivera
jamais le président restera aussi
longtemps que le peuple syrien le voudra
et pour être plus précis l'objectif de
ces sanctions et d'influencer l'élection
présidentielle qui approche et quiconque
dira le contraire se trompent
une élection présidentielle qui aura
lieu dans un an avec les mêmes enjeux
que ces législatives répondre à une
crise protéiforme sans précédent pour
permettre aux syriens de retrouver une
vie normale
pour rappel 80% de la population
syrienne vit au dessous du seuil de
pauvreté selon le programme alimentaire
mondial de l'onu et le kobe 19 à
aggraver un peu plus la situation du
pays le pib estimée en 2019 à seulement
un tiers de ce qu'il était avant la
guerre sera encore plus bas en 2020
maintenant c'est ta première interview
d'eric dupond-moretti en tant que garde
des sceaux donnée au jdd il a présenté
ses priorités la direction qui devrait
donner à son ministère pendant six jours
à de la lutte contre les violences
conjugales à la fermeté face au
terrorisme en passant par les réformes
du parquet eric dupond-moretti défend
une injustice proche des citoyens parmi
ces impératifs
les conditions en prison que l'ancien
avocat connaissent je veux réconcilier
les français avec leur justice leur
redonner confiance
c'est pourquoi je parle d'une justice de
proximité
je connais les prisons j'y suis allé
tant de fois comme avocat il y existe de
bonnes pratiques pour améliorer les
conditions de détention
il faut les généraliser c'est tout à
l'heure avec jean françois forget
secrétaire général unsa justice et
surveillants brigadier à la maison
d'arrêt de carcassonne propose de
l'écouter on est dans la tempe puisque
nous rencontrons mercredi on verra je
veux dire que on a fait des procès
d'intention fait à certains ont fait des
procès d'intention à d'autres et on n'a
pas vu les résultats
qu'on pouvait imaginer donc voilà faut
lui laisser sa chance pour autant on lui
dira nous très franchement ce que l'on
attend de lui
ce qu'on attend du gouvernement et s'il
veut parler de proximité s'il veut
parler de de justice de proximité si
vous parlez de conditions détention il
va tomber sur sur des sur un syndicat le
mien moi qui connaît son sujet qu'il y
aura des propositions allaient faire ça
dit pas à grand chose de plus que les
annonces qui ont été les siennes les
propos qu'il a tenus depuis le début je
pense que il fait attention à peser
chaque mot il essaie de corriger déjà
les premiers égarements du premier
ministre puisque celui ci a annoncé le
retour des juges de proximité on en est
loin visiblement et heureusement
et en tout état de cause concernant les
conditions de détention puisque sur ce
sujet là il dit qu'il veut s'attaquer à
cette difficulté la mettre en lumière et
dynamiser des projets qui sont
efficients tout à fait c'est
certainement les projets que nous avons
mis en place
l'ufap/unsa-justice ce que nous avons
proto colisée avec nicole belloubet et
pour lequel on souhaite effectivement
qu'il soit étendu sur l'ensemble des 188
établissements il avait 29 ans est mort
noyé dans le canal saint denis à
aubervilliers
un hommage lui était rendu cet après
midi à proximité du lieu du drame à les
circonstances dans lesquelles ces jeunes
migrants soudanais est mort restent pour
l'instant floue comme des centaines
d'hommes venus d'afrique de l'est
d'afghanistan et du maghreb
il avait
échoués sur les berges du canal et
vivait dans un campement misérable qui
s'est rapidement a été tendue depuis la
fin du confinement et ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'un migrant meurt en
région parisienne écouter de mémoire il
ya eu une personne qui est morte je
crois le mois dernier un peu plus haut
dans le canal au bassin de la mal tourné
parce que dans
il a voulu repêché un ballon qui
modifient fait tomber dans le canal il
est bluffé noyer et puis il y en a au
moins encore deux mais dont je ne
connais plus fous des conditions de
décès ce sont des gens qui fuient la
famille qui fuient la guerre qui fuit
donc les donc c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
là ils ne sont pas là parce que c'est
plus ça leur fait plaisir
donc il faut absolument que l'état
reprenne vraiment 7 7 7
cette chose parce que c'est mais ça
n'est plus possible de de durer comme ça
attention dès demain entrera en vigueur
l'obligation du port du masque dans les
lieux publics clos partout dans
l'hexagone le port d'une protection sera
sanctionné le non port d'une protection
sera sanctionnée d'une amende de 135
euros
olivier ferrand le ministre de la santé
l'a précisé et cette mesure sachez
qu'elle est déjà effective depuis hier
dans l'ensemble du département de la
mayenne placée depuis mercredi en
vulnérabilités dès lundi le port du
masque sera obligatoire dans les lieux
clos comme l'annoncé jean castex
cela concerne les commerces
établissements recevant du public
marché couvert banque gestes-barrières
et dépistage reste essentielle pour
lutter efficacement contre le virus et
on craint une deuxième vague épidémique
qui se matérialise peu à peu un rang
confinement peut-être le gouvernement en
tout cas étudient sérieusement cette
piste pas de confinement généralisée
mais des territoires des villes
des quartiers entiers un plan
interministériel détaillants quatre
types de scénarios serait en cours de
finalisation hier soir le premier
ministre
jean castex a déclaré que la france
devait être prête à toute éventualité
siens et pour robert a quand même média
train fonctionnant de l'hôpital
intercommunal de créteil dans le
val-de-marne à un confinement total
comme en mars dernier paraît peu
probable mais il insiste sur le respect
du port du masque quand on est dans la
rue à distance des autres quand on fait
du sport quand on se promène et qu'on
n'est pas dans un milieu fork fermé il
n'y a pas vraiment d'utilité à porter un
masque
quand on est à linverse dans un milieu
où il ya beaucoup de montées que c'est
fermé
à l'évidence de masques s'impose de
façon certaine d'où l'obligation entre
les deux on peut trouver des situations
où on se retrouve avec beaucoup de monde
très proche est à l'aise dans la rue et
là le masque est conseillé il faut voir
cet ensemble de situations là le marque
c'est pas pour tout le temps il est fait
pour les milieux coule au public où il
ya du monde il est obligatoire dans son
droit
il est conseillé dans un certain nombre
d'autres de conditions et je pense
qu'avec ça on doit éviter d re
confinement lâche n'est pas exclu qu'on
puisse être confiné un quartier une
région mais à coup finement généraliser
je crois que c'est très très peu
probable
sachez que hong kong enregistre
aujourd'hui une centaine de nouveaux
câbles coronavirus et puis cette
décision immédiate du gouvernement il
s'agit du port obligatoire d'un masque
dans tous les lieux publics intérieurs
une réglementation prise quelques jours
après à le renforcement des mesures face
à une situation qui s'aggrave salle de
sport et discothèques sont fermés car il
amena chef de l'exécutif d'hong kong a
souligné lors d'une conférence de presse
qu' aujourd'hui
rien n'indique que la propagation du
coronavirus est maîtrisée dans
l'ancienne colonie britannique selon l
écouter la situation est vraiment
critique et rien n'indique que la
situation soit maîtrisé c'est pourquoi
j'ai convoqué ce matin une nouvelle
réunion de haut niveau pour examiner la
réponse et nous pensons que le public
sera très inquiet et préoccupé
cette série d'épidémie concernent
principalement des cas locaux nous
devons donc réagir rapidement
comme je les dis cette vague de
transmission est encore plus critique
est plus difficile à combattre
si je peux m'exprimer ainsi car elle
implique beaucoup plus de groupes de
différentes natures
nous avons maintenant des maisons de
soins pour personnes âgées pour la
première fois il ya une épidémie est
maintenant une deuxième maison de soins
pour personnes âgées est impliqué et
puis nous avons eu un groupe de
restaurants et un autre de logements
sociaux et même des écoles et de
nombreuses industries différentes sont
également touchés cela signifie dont il
y avait beaucoup plus de canaux de
transmission
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on va se retrouver
en direct dans 30 minutes rester avec
nous sur rtl france
[Musique]
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rend compte que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer au soir vous avez proposé deux
posters en falck faire que ça veut dire
facile à lire ça si la comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris